Hello?
Hi, Amanda!
How have you been?
Not so good.
I'm on my way back home.
Are you sick?
I think I caught a cold.
That's not good.
What symptoms do you have?
I keep coughing and sneezing.
Do you have a fever, too?
Not only a fever but also a headache!
Did you see a doctor?
Yes. He prescribed me some medicine.
Don't forget to take a rest.
That always helps.
Thank you.
I'll keep that in mind.
Oh! I forgot about the appointment with the dentist!
Do you have a toothache, too?
Yes. I think my wisdom tooth is breaking through.
Does it hurt?
A little bit.
I think I'm going to have it pulled out.
Good thinking.
You'd better find a good dentist.
Is it that painful?
It depends on the dentist's skill.